las secuelas del estallido social de
chile continúan a día de hoy la comisión
de derechos humanos del senado aprobó un
proyecto de ley para indultar a los
detenidos en la ola de protestas
iniciada en octubre de 2019
durante meses cientos de personas se han
estado concentrando todos los viernes en
el centro de la capital para exigir la
libertad de los presos a pesar de las
restricciones contra el kobe 19
los familiares han recogido 5000 firmas
en una carta que pide que no se vete la
ley la iniciativa reconoce que muchas
personas cometieron actos punibles pero
alegan razones humanitarias y
excepcionales más de 5 mil personas
fueron detenidas durante el estallido de
las cuales 2.180 pasaron a prisión
preventiva el presidente sebastián
piñera está decidido a vetar la ley de
salir adelante atenta contra el orden
público la seguridad ciudadana la
democracia y el estado de derecho
el 6 de octubre de 2019 subió el precio
del pasaje del transporte público de
santiago fueron unos 4 centavos de dólar
desde ese momento empezaron unas
protestas que dejaron más de 30 muertos
centenares de mutilados oculares miles
de heridos violaciones de los derechos
humanos y detenidos
el estallido dio lugar a un referendo
constitucional que en octubre de 2020
fue aprobado por la ciudadanía el 11 de
abril serán elegidos los 155 miembros de
la constituyente que tratarán de
modernizar un país en el que rige una
carta magna heredada del dictador
augusto pinochet
puedes